wir stehen vor einer großen
Herausforderung mittlerweile kann man
sein dass mindestens jeder fünfte
Deutsche tatsächlich psychisch
herausgefordert ist instabil ist und das
wirkt sich auf verschiedenste Art und
Weise aus das heißt wir können
feststellen dass gerade die Kleinsten
der Kleinen da wird gleich Carsten Star
wahrscheinlich auch was zu sagen können
darunter massiv bleiben noch nie in
unserer Geschichte in Deutschland waren
Jugend und Kinderpsychiatrie so
überlaufen in Zeiten des corona-wahns
gab es nur eine einzige Triage in
Deutschland die fand in dem Psychiatrien
statt man musste schon mit Selbstmord
drohen um tatsächlich eingeliefert oder
aufgenommen zu werden aber es kümmert
sich da keiner drum wir müssen uns
selber darum kümmern Gott sei Dank
gibt's aus psychologischer Sicht immer
wieder Chancen was wir für uns tun
können damit wir resilient und
widerstandsfähig bleiben egal wie groß
der Wahnsinn um uns